[Music]  you always y'all y'all y'all y'all  Jackie Chan says rush hour for is  happening right here with some salt Raja  will probably rush hour for here next  year next yeah do you understand the  words tonight coming all over my mouth  that's right fans are now closer to  getting another sequel but is co-star  Chris Tucker in Chris not good you you  you don't let me see me I forget you  come on buddy  Jackie told power 106 is the crew show  it took seven years to find the right  script and whether Chris is on board  will depend on scheduling it's not my  money it's about it's about time to make  otherwise for the fans  yeah rush off for we're all like oh man  before we can oh please  one thing's clear fans and Jackie  himself are holding out for agent Carter  and Lee to be back on the big screen  together those kinda movie I know the  audio and they like it do you like it I  make it  [Music]  you  [Music]